Now that we've calculated the
change in potential energy
between some initial
and final heights
for the gravitational problem,
mg of y final minus y initial.
For this conservative
force of gravity,
and we had our coordinate
system like that,
we were able to calculate the
change in potential energy.
And remember our theorem is that
non-conservative work equals
Delta K plus Delta U.
Now what we'd like
to do is establish
the concept of a reference
point for potential energy.
And we'll do that
as follows, see
the change in potential
energy only depended
on say, our initial state
and our final state.
What we'd like to do is
introduce the concept
of a reference point.
So let's identify some point
Yp to be our reference point.
And we'll define a potential Yp
to be the reference potential.
And if we want to talk
about the potential energy
in a final state,
we'll always refer it
to the difference between
that and the reference point.
So this is Delta U between the
final state and the reference
point.
Likewise, for the
initial state, we'll
always refer that with respect
to our reference point.
So any state that we
have, we can always
refer the potential energy
difference between some state
and some reference point.
Why do we do this?
Because notice that if we look
at U final minus U reference
point, and we subtract from
that U initial minus U reference
point, then the
difference-- the reference
points here we have a
minus, here we have a plus--
this is just equal
to U final minus U
initial, which is Delta U.
So the change in potential
energy between any two states
is independent of how we
choose our reference potential.
But it can make
calculations easier
when we can identify what
the potential energy is
for a little state.
Now let's look at our example.
So for our
gravitational problem we
will choose y reference
point to be 0.
And we'll choose the potential
energy at this reference point
also to be 0.
So our reference potential
at the origin is 0,
and I'll denote it like that.
Then the potential energy
at some initial state
minus the reference
point-- well,
we can use our formula
here, because this
is between any two states.
So this is mg y initial
minus the reference point.
But our reference
point was 0, and so we
see that U initial minus y
reference point, which was also
0, is just equal to mg Yi.
And so we have this statement
that the potential energy
difference between our initial
state and the reference point
is just mg where
Yi is the height
that the initial state is
above the reference point.
In a similar way, we have
U final is mg y final.
And so we see we
recover what we expect.
This is just mg y
final minus y initial.
Now this we can generalize
just a little bit
by saying that for
any-- let's write
that for us our mass,
which is for any height y
our potential energy function
for the gravitational force
U(y) is equal to mg y.
That's a formula that many
of you have seen before.
But it's very important to note
that with this formula, U of 0
equals 0, because that's
our reference point.
And that becomes our
potential energy function
for the gravitational force.
Now our next step will
be to do the same thing
for spring forces and inverse
square gravitational forces.
And we'll also look at graphical
analysis of this function.